hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play what where am
I
no that's not what we're playing we're
playing slender haunt which means that's
Lundy is right on my ass that's right
oh I remember now yeah I'm about to die
oh yeah okay so I got seven of ten and
now I know I need to go south again
because I need to hit up some places in
the forest I've mostly been on the woods
or not I've most have been out of the
woods and on the trail where I buzzy
buzzy was he in front of me behind me hi
oh wow no you know it's get away get
away don't need any of that
thank you very much so Fanny Hill green
in I'm right here I can go south
basically follow this road all the way
down to where I need to go unless this
isn't south and I just took it all wrong
road again actually I'm gonna cut
straight through the woods
cuz I'm willing to bet there's tons of
places in the woods that I have not
found and I shouldn't have picked gamer
I should have picked noob Who am I
trying to kid oh don't do that
oh no oh no oh don't be like that you're
such an a-hole
cuz I know he's right he's not behind me
right now but he's gonna be I hear him
stabby keying around back there oh man
not how I wanted to start off my day but
that's how they then go
okay so I hear you I hear you stay back
ah what's that something not the normal
something but like the bone like a bass
drum being hit I don't know I'm kind of
just lost now and I just hit the road
again I missed something in those woods
I might have I just went in a straight
line right through them Who am I trying
to fool
Oh what do wait where am I
which way through the woods did I go
where did I know this can't be right hey
I'm back in the woods again does it say
I'm where am I
oh I went to the side and if I go if I
go back maybe I'll hit that tree and
double-check to see if I got the page
off of the creepy tree I don't know I
don't know I also know there's like a
shed in the middle of the woods what is
that like ah what whoa what happened
they grant on the edge of my flashlight
I see the outline of something is that
the factory see the outline of just
something like right on my flashlight I
can see outlines
it was tiny so that must have been
towards the faculty which means it this
way is ease ah the tree that's what was
being weird okay I did already get the
page over here it stuck a tree [ __ ]
I'll bet you can't navigate with all
your slithering about you glide like a
lizard on ice I've gone the wrong way in
our day I hey was you in front of me
that's not allowed landmarks again aha
that is the factory over there bees if I
don't go that way I'll be fine Oh get oh
hi Jesus holy balls I need to get back
to a save because I got another page
back where is this off then ah [ __ ] did
the bunker I need to go this way
hopefully he will have chilled and I'll
be able to go
man this guy this this silly [ __ ] man
it's like that one if you ever go to the
subreddit where did the soda go
it took one with this lady's serving
mashed potatoes and it's just a stupid
just gift from those infomercials and
this guy the dad of the family I suppose
it's like glue you know the Fidesz go
and someone captain wore this [ __ ] I've
tried it I've tried to humor eyes things
whenever it's not working okay I need to
go still more to the south follow this
road hey I'm out of breath I need to
stop spamming this bread five stages
permit harder that's what I need to do
where am I going oh no it Huss Huss I
need the house so badly ah ah I'm the
winner
maybe maybe maybe or maybe later I will
feel to figure out that I really lost
okay stop it
I can't sprint anymore you dick I need
to get in here I need to get out why do
you have a chef that [ __ ] why was he in
the house or was he in the house huh huh
anybody want to answer me then why was
he in the house why was he wearing a
chef's hat I have so many questions
did he comment was that a different
slender man was that chef Slendy and he
popped out of the girl who's in my house
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
I walked right into a mouse trying to
get to this save point so badly and I
walked right into him okay but anyway
well now that I'm back I know where I
need to go right if I just calm down and
stop sprinting I'd be able to judge
where I am now run into him so much
whatever I know I didn't say if I'm
gonna new position where is it frizzy
where is he buddy nah ah come on
huh nothing had enough air I can't get
out oh oh you fell down the hill ha ha
alrighty down there oh oh are you static
eating everything for y'all you took the
dick I'm gonna go run away now are you
stuck at the bottom of hill laughs I
can't believe that worked
I guess it's because he's not really a
teleport based Slendy when he's coming
after you but he kind of slides torching
out so he can slide right up hill oh
it's gonna be like that huh it's gonna
be like that well if I'm walking it
doesn't tell me for me back that far
see if I stop panicking for two seconds
and go about my business no time to
panic must panic harder okay so if I go
straight into these woods this is the
woods that had the thingy oh god get
away get away get away I'm not afraid of
you I'm not afraid of you no matter what
about twenty other videos say uh I was
walking back up the hill I suppose fire
around the hill down the hill good
alright
big wavy lines oh no effect I can't jump
I'm up handsy okay so stop running
I hear him but I know he's not gonna get
me right maybe maybe that's how this is
gonna work I don't know oh god I love
this game so much okay you didn't he's
messing with me he's messing with my
mind
my mind is already left about ten years
ago okay are you gonna stop teleporting
me now I don't think you're teleporting
me that much before okay what am I
looking at what is this oh wow that's
convenient I'm not gonna bring it you
shut your face Wow there is this good
pointing straight towards it hi
yeah I guess the signs are here to help
me out I never really noticed them
before maybe because I died I don't know
but I'm walking calmly okay I'm going
back the way I came maybe I can go up
that hill and hit the save again there's
this situations getting dicey getting
dicey here I know there's that wait no
there's a cabin in the woods over this
way I know there is in the middle of
this field of this field I know there's
a cabin here that has another page
because I found it before enough leave
Lee is completely I found it before in a
previous playthrough ok f off thank you
very much so long as I don't run
straight into him I should be fine
I know Tracy outline of this with my
flashlight something over there I think
that might be something
ling-ling it haha no typewriter though I
might baby buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
yeah okay so that's eight of ten nine of
ten actually holy crap I need to save
all right let's try to head back to the
hill let's see this is really convenient
now that I know I can trace out lines
and stuff like this that's just the
woods woods big tree that looks like
okay it must be bad yeah this way wait
what's this sign say poisonous woods no
that's where I already got I already got
from the tree boys in this woods maybe I
don't know I'll go back there if I need
to see uh tiny Hill this way yeah I
think that might be a new one so I'll go
back there right now I know I guess okay
poisonous would do not across poisonous
plants ah
good thing I ain't no [ __ ] it's Reno
point uh haha holy crap holy coming at
the dawn I don't kill me buddy there was
a key behind this crap what oh I got a
key Holly crap I'm uh gotta get back to
the tiny Hill what is that
was that in the middle to her battery's
good you got to get to the tiny Hill
tiny Hill tiny Oh cuz I know whoa
Oh
[Music]
what is that that's an alarm oh oh I bet
you all are surprised watching me right
now okay you're like marks actually
making ogress say what but how how does
he do that i watch his i watch these
videos all the time he does not do that
oh come on Ron man gotta get to this
save ah why are you going so slow up the
freakin Hill what's wrong with you are
you really encumbered by all of those
pieces of paper I guess that key must
weigh 10,000 pounds
jeez I said I wasn't a little [ __ ] oh
no no I can't run don't get me now don't
get me no not now no no not now why why
I bet he'll why are you such an [ __ ]
why are you such an [ __ ] and why did
my running speed suddenly take a
nosedive I've been doing fine before
even my walking I can't
[ __ ] him going to the factory there's
a safe point in there hopefully I'll be
able to save myself from the agony that
is my life oh now you can run oh right
now right now it'd be an overnight now
now would be the time to run oh you're
such a little [ __ ] I hate you I hate
you
whoever the character is you can't even
hold his flashlight properly
it's got like I don't know okay so wait
what's in this check something I need
nothing I need apparently let's say was
a save point in that Shack which I've
that I highly doubt that okay I know the
entrance is whenever I find a road here
up on the laughs okay it's calmly and
collectively okay I know what's up that
road I'm just checking cuz I would love
but say point no uh-huh hey give it to
me it's up this way ha ha run around you
run around you run around you and I ride
ya up this Hill up this Yap this why you
gotta be standing right exactly on the
places that I need to be why do you do
that are you programmed to be an [ __ ]
oh come on oh come on screw it I'm just
going toward the light through
everything else I'm going towards the
light that do not crow I think it said I
believe I believe that was do not crow
wait hang on where's ah wait maybe I
wasn't as close to the thing dong is I
thought I was don't oh don't oh you dick
oh you add so wait no I'm going wait no
ah hi back off buddy
no this wrong is wrong where the hell is
the entrance I can't be on the wrong
side of the whole map can I stop flick
of plaque ring come on give me the ding
dong I found it before and [ __ ] she's
chasing me off of everywhere I need to
go such an [ __ ]
oh come on don't be like this don't be
like this where's the flimflamming
entrance oh come on not a can you whoa I
hate you so much Lenny ah damn you're
making me go way over time just trying
to find a freaking entrance a save point
anything [ __ ]
you're such an [ __ ] you're such an
[ __ ]
is the biggest dick right now that I've
ever seen every time I go somewhere that
I need to go look good there
I bet he's camping off the entrance Oh
finally god I knew I was going the right
way the first time okay do not Oh [ __ ]
please
I will I will I will Jack slap the [ __ ]
out of you Slendy if you don't back the
[ __ ] off
Danko Jamis Kristoff where's a save
give me a save there's a save what did
that how do I get into you here Hulka
here you
[Music]
save save save save another page oh I
thought it was done with pages this to
scraps left to scraps left I thought I
got hey I guess I got Oh 60 seconds to
get up what I saw that tree branch I'll
go up there ah crap I didn't know that
and know that I'm not saved screw you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that God it
kept being such a dick
oh right on the hell turn around go back
a hoodie right there and I forgot booter
hard friendiy sorry
okay
I know where the pages are to get it
back into the vector in the near
vicinity give me a few minutes at most
to get them
the factory but before I do that I'll
get the base are now saved
okay so thank you all so much for
watching cooking it tastes boy that he
said I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
haha I have you now you don't see me
[Music]